esta escena podría formar parte de una
película es la actriz rusa yulia perejil
que se prepara para despegar en una
misión a la estación espacial
internacional
viajando con un equipo de la agencia
espacial rusa roscósmos la actriz y su
director atacaron una estación espacial
para filmar escenas de la primera
película que se realizará en el espacio
el equipo de filmación pasará 12 días en
la estación espacial donde el astronauta
francés thomas pesquet es el comandante
pesquet no aparecerá en la película pero
los cosmonautas rusos estarán entre los
extras la actriz y directora entrenó
durante 12 semanas antes del lanzamiento
al espacio emocionado hasta el carroccio
stroke nos preparamos lo mejor que
pudimos en tan poco tiempo en cualquier
caso fue una experiencia tan solo viento
y masa verdad ahora ni nada por el
estilo estaba muy emocionada feliz
porque muy pocas personas tienen la
oportunidad de ir al espacio desde
gestos como semi prostíbulos y fusión la
trama y el presupuesto de la película se
han mantenido en su mayor parte en
secreto sólo se conoce hasta ahora que
la historia se centra en una cirujana
que es enviada a la estación espacial
para salvar a un cosmonauta 40 minutos
en la película se filman en gravedad
cero
visibilidad es muy difícil filmar la
gravedad cero en la tierra es casi
imposible reproducirlo con precisión
emilia la tripulación rusa está lista
para superar un proyecto de hollywood
anunciado por tom cruise y space ex de
elon musk el año pasado la primera etapa
de la misión ya está completada
superando así a sus rivales
estadounidenses al segundo lugar en la
carrera por filmar una película en
órbita y sumando una larga lista de
novedades para la industria espacial
rusa
[Música]